well every Disney cember we try to look
at the best that Disney has to offer
this year we're gonna go the opposite
route if you're younger you might have
noticed all these sequels that seem to
pop up too popular Disney films that
don't really seem to be as good this is
because as hand-drawn films were
starting to phase out and CG films were
starting to phase in Disney didn't
always have a lot to do for their
hand-drawn department at least nothing
that made that much of profit however
that seemed to change though not
necessarily for the best with the
direct-to-dvd sequels for whatever
reason kids just love to see what was
going to happen next in these movies
that really didn't need any continuing
stories and they got a reputation pretty
fast of being the worst
you name it Lion King Aladdin Pocahontas
even The Hunchback of Notre 'adam got a
sequel as they seem to make more and
more money they pushed him out faster
and faster and well they have a
reputation for being some of Disney's
worst material in recent years for a
long time people have been asking me to
look these over and by god I didn't want
to but you know what I'm an optimist and
I'm gonna hold out hope that there's at
least one just one good sequel out there
is it a fool's wish maybe but I'm
determined to get through all of them to
see if they're as bad as everybody says
they were I get a feeling they're right
but I should judge for myself even
though there's surprisingly enough films
to almost fill the entire month there's
still one or two that I have available
yeah so I'll fill those in with not
sequels but still direct-to-dvd movies
that they make is there somewhere a
diamond in the rough to be found well
all through the month of December I'm
gonna find out because you demanded it
this is Disney cember directed DVD
sequence I hope you appreciate what I do
for you
so let's go to where this all started I
remember I got the VHS of Fox in the
hound as soon as you open it up there
was a little pamphlet that said one of
the greatest villains was coming back
you opened it up and you saw Disney's
the return of Jafar
holy smokes to a little kid this was
amazing Aladdin was one of the biggest
films that ever came out at that time
and Disney never really did any sequels
apart from the rescuers down under so we
were beyond excited to see another
Aladdin movie on the big screen as more
time went by though we realized it
wasn't gonna be on the big screen it was
gonna be direct a VHS well okay it was
still an Aladdin sequel and it was done
by Disney it still has to be pretty good
right well then we saw the trailer for
it and man there is a serious downgrade
it was pretty obvious from the first
frame what this was this was Disney
trying to cash in on a popular movie
which they've done before but not
usually with a sequel and not usually
with such a difference in animation so
yeah the hype died down pretty quickly
but I'm still kind of interested in
seeing it after all it was Aladdin and
we want to know what evil scheme Jafar
had up his sleeve the film centers
around Aladdin getting used to his new
palace life and apparently still unable
to put on a shirt when Diago the parrot
escapes from Jafar's lamp and tosses it
away trying to convince Aladdin in the
gang day's change for good even though
he really just wants a new position of
power on top of that the genie returns
to as sort of rabble Eames didn't come
back to voice in this time and it really
shows they got dan Castellaneta the
voice of Homer Simpson to do him instead
and to be fair it's not a bad choice he
can do a pretty good impression but so
much of the genie was Robin Williams
just doing his improv and nobody's as
good as him so immediately it's a little
distracting but your fire returns as
well as a thief played by Jason
Alexander accidentally releases him and
Jafar as the genie promises to grant him
his wishes if he follows through with
his revenge
so Jafar plans his evil scheme by
framing a lead and making it look like
he killed the Sultan all while locking
up everybody else away the plot in
general is not that bad and to its
credit of Farr's revenge is
actually a pretty good one but nothing
feels as fleshed out as the original in
fact Aladdin doesn't even seem like the
focus it feels more like the focuses on
Diago he's the one that has the story
arc he's the one that's torn between two
places but in terms of what made the
original Aladdin so enjoyable and
continuing it here a lot of it just
doesn't transfer over whether they
didn't have the time or the budget or
whatever it just feels really rushed
aladdin and Jasmine don't have much
chemistry the genies not really that
funny the animation though I know
they're trying just can't compete with
the incredible colors and movement that
the first one had even the songs aren't
as hummable and yeah way too many of
them are given to Gilbert Godfrey
because that's a voice I want to hear
put to music I remember when my brother
and I first saw it we were more making
fun of it than actually getting sucked
into the story but again being kids we
did put it on once or twice after we
kind of accepted what it was just a
cheap knockoff rushed out really fast
and I guess a cheap knockoffs go it's
not the worst it's just not very good
its purpose is made totally complete by
the ending where it just seems to end
really abruptly they just say hey we
want to go see the world and it just
kind of stops I remember we were
scratching our heads what that was about
and then a few days later the Aladdin
cartoon show came out so yeah really all
this was was a pilot episode for the
Aladdin cartoon honestly I probably
would have liked it more if it just came
forward and said that's what this was if
they just announced there was an Aladdin
show coming out and this was going to be
the first episode or a couple of
episodes tied together like what they
usually do with the Disney Afternoon
but no they had to put it on VHS slap
return of Jafar on it and thus we now
have to judge it as a Disney movie not a
theatrical release but still a sequel to
a theatrical release and in that case
it's pretty bad what would have made a
passable TV pilot is now the beginning
of a long line of disappointing DVD
sequels the only part that kind of gets
a chuckle every once in a while as Jason
Alexander as the thief but that's
because it's Jason Alexander and
anything he touches is hilarious well
almost Disney did manage to crush
once but even when he's saying unfunny
lines he can get a little bit of a laugh
out of him he's just that good as for
the rest I think the word to describe it
is probably awkward it's not god-awful
it's not like there was no effort put
into it it's just awkward looking back
years later it's not that big a deal
especially we know all the sequels Erica
come out after but for a bunch of kids
that were excited to finally see a
sequel to one of the biggest Disney
films they've ever seen
it was pretty underwhelming I know it
has a soft spot for some I was just
never one to get into it but this would
only be the beginning of the Disney
sequels suckfest war we're on the way
and there was so much more suffering to
be had